what would I hope my musical Legacy is I
hope that the people that I love
remember that I wasn't so much of a dick
for the most part
[Music]
Ants Marching was pretty early on maybe
the most recognizable of our earlier
Tunes I met a lot of the guys when I was
bartending so I met Carter I think
probably at the bar where I was working
Miller's probably a became friendly with
Leroy there he played there quite a bit
Straight Ahead Jazz stuff and I think I
knew Stefan from that period too I wrote
four songs and we all said we decided
we'd get together and the idea was maybe
we'd make some recordings or something
but because we only had a limited
repertoire we exploited the guys who
could play jazz there was a lot more
improvisation when you only had a few
songs so he slowly added more and more
to that and songs like Ants Marching by
the time we went into the studio I guess
we'd probably been playing together for
about three years or so and we had quite
a big audience and whether or not we or
what we're doing is in style there was
an eagerness for us to get into the
studio but we didn't know who to go in
with you know because a lot of producers
you know at that time would be like you
know this is how you do this is how you
make a rock record or this is how you
make a pop record but we were like well
we already have something that's
dragging all these people out to come
and see we have this energy that's
really different so I think one of the
reasons we chose Steve Lilly white for
those early sessions was when he spoke
to us about recordings he said I don't
want to change anything he said I just
want to get what you do on stage he was
genuine about it and he had this
humility about the way he he said that
is that is that he didn't know how he
was going to do it but he said it he
knew that it had to be possible because
there's microphones and there's tapes
and and so what we ended up doing was
you know really just playing more and
more and more and it really was his idea
it's like once you had an arrangement
that you're going to put down he just
said just keep playing it and playing it
and we really did until it started
getting worse and then that was sort of
the one he said that's that that would
be the take
we started Ants Marching with just a
straight snare hit
[Music]
and he just remembers hearing this God
I think it was like 20 snare hits he was
like this is insane and he said whatever
happens next it better be good because
this is pissing me off
[Music]
satellite was like a challenging lick I
like to watch like Robert Fripp and how
he played but he has got this crazy way
of playing it's like this thing his
hands are all spread out and he gets all
this coverage which is unnecessary if
your guitar is tuned to you know like a
like traditionally it made me like just
mess around with that feeling of being
spread out and then also another friend
of mine had said why do rock bands
always do everything in A and E and you
know C it's the wow they ever do
anything like in a flat or or you know E
flat I was like well because you know
because all the chords are down there
you know and so it that made me think
well if I'm doing this weird spread I
think I can find a pattern that works
that
that looks kind of like Robert Fripp but
is unnecessary
um and is a flat you know
[Music]
so the way I first learned to play it
and sing at the same time it was sort of
like an exercise I would just play it
over and over again and I would try and
talk while I was doing it and I'd make
up silly lyrics to it it taught me that
you can separate my uh voice from my
guitar like one could be the marching
orders and the other one could be
singing and dancing flying around those
structure a little bit more
[Music]
um maybe I don't always know why I start
something and usually really if I'm
right you know who lyrics are not easy
some people are really good at it but
the songs that I'm Unapologetic about
are the ones that come quickly then they
don't have time to get dragged through
the gravel or through the dirt and then
I don't think too clinically about them
but I imagine that a therapist might
look at Satellite and say that's about
death or about loss or about accepting
that it is lost and so then if you
looked at my life you'd say well his dad
died but then you know but my my dog
died too so it could be about my dog
[Music]
crash is odd because it's a Love Song
and I've dribbled on about what it was
about but it was very much at the
beginning of the partnership I'm still
in and that's where it came from there's
always a funny regret that I have
because there's this throwaway line that
while we're recording that I jokingly at
the end of the song about the skirt that
I threw in there in one take as a joke
[Music]
show your world to me the rest of it is
sort of for me was always a little bit
lighter but it made the whole thing more
about sex than maybe I wanted to admit
it was but then if I look at the song
for me it's a pretty sexy song it's hard
for me to sing it now that I'm uh in the
second half
it's like that's what I like to call it
of my time this is a song of a 26 year
old a 25 year old now I'm a 56 year old
so then the change is what you want to
sing about I mean I still want to sing
about it but I'm like easy pal you know
rein it in I throw my back out too often
to sing that song
[Music]
I was really grateful because that made
me look at it a little differently the
term autonomy of art I always liked that
idea that once you finish something if
you put it in the world it's no longer
yours and what it means what you
intended doesn't matter anymore and I
like that idea because then it also
takes some of the responsibility off of
me but um Camina Mountain to somebody
else and I might have just intended a
molehill you know
[Music]
sorry
to read
[Music]
I have no idea what number it was it
could have been 41 and that's a nice way
to think about it but I also think
that
I had no idea what the book I was
talking about because I've had people
talk to talk to me about that song and
how much it means them and I'm like what
well maybe you can sit down and explain
it all to me there's some good lines in
that and it's definitely got some
stuff to it and I like playing that song
but also because I don't know what the
hell whoever wrote it is talking about
so I can talk to you about the lyrics
too much it's you know there's some
loneliness in there there's some loss
some aware of all the good times gone
kind of feel to it a little bit of that
too but I don't know I don't know it
seems pretty obtuse to me what is it
about a goat or world war three I don't
know which one but it's clearly about
one of the two
we're friends of mine people close to me
say what do you think the best song you
ever wrote is and I that's the first one
every time I have nothing to apologize
for that it's like I was as clear as I
could be you know what why am I mad at
the history of like of North America the
thing I'm mad at us about is all of the
knowledge and all of the culture and all
of the perspective that we erased for
greed and but for all generations to
come to steal the future away from our
children the idea of
conquering people is deeply misguided
arrogant and stupid I realize that the
best way for me to say that was to be
the villain and that's the part that I'd
like so much about that song is like
being the hunter you know where the
skulls I've got a crush because this is
all mine and then of course the the
reflection is sort of looking back that
don't drink the water part is turning
around and facing what you've done but
we still do it that's what we do
else
the line
I think what's interesting in America is
uh in the U.S and we we've told this
oversimplified story that the racism of
America primarily existed in the South
but the truth is when you look at our
history and the racism is everywhere
here in Seattle no one could that wasn't
white could live in this neighborhood 60
years ago
less than that probably and of course it
was enormously Central to the South but
then when I talked to people in Virginia
or Louisiana and you talk to people
about race and race issues you might
find the most overtly secessionist or
whatever but you also find in my opinion
the most aggressively Progressive people
in the country down there is the front
line so that's where you find the people
that have changed the country because
that's so much of where it happened of
course it happened everywhere but it
really happened there a lot of the hopes
of that we have for resolving the
problems in this country will be found
in the Southeast I still think the space
between
I loved the process of making that
record it was different for all of us as
well and I think the resulting record
was good I was you know a lot of people
said it doesn't sound like you like your
other records but then again that
doesn't doesn't bother me because it's
not the same bit of music then once we
started playing a lot of those songs
live I remember talking to Glenn about
it because he came to a show and after
hearing how he played the songs after
we've been playing them for a year him
saying man I wish we could go back in
and make that record again something
changes you know when something sort of
gets uh sewn into
your being a little bit I think it's a
incredibly beautiful record and I like
that it sounds different and it deserves
to sound different
[Music]
that song is uh unintentionally
um had a really beautiful resonance when
it first you know after 9 11 that was a
different thing and people were looking
at that in a different way you know I
can remember going into New York like a
week after 9 11 I remember a plane flew
over the city where we're all standing
outside smoking cigarettes everyone
stopped it's like all the truckers and
everyone everyone was just standing
looking up because you know no one it
was the first planes that had flown over
the city it was such a creepy weird
desperate sad time I will say that on
that record that there was a song we
still played I love that song called
when the world ends when the world ended
supposed to be released to the single
but they wouldn't let it because it's
described sort of this crumbling City
and then it was sort of banned from the
radio which was funny because you know
if I was going to have a song band it's
funny that it was a cheesy love song but
I don't mind the irony
me
staring out onto Gray Street that song
seems uplifting but it's just you know
the noise of the traffic it's noisy and
boisterous but uh
it's about somebody who lives you know
who's alone that's even more so now when
you look at how lonely people are when
we're all so connected and it's kind of
fun to look in a traffic jam to look at
all these different cars or all these
different Windows where novels of
stories are happening in every single
one of those you know or every house and
that happens eight billion times over
but it's incredible how isolated
we are when there's so many of us here
and so that song's just about even when
people are trying to sort of reach into
us and help us out that the true
loneliness that we all exist in is
inescapable if we obsess on ourselves
[Music]
the song's not directly about my
political views on guns because it's not
really political it's just are you
insane or are you not insane
I know I have a lot of friends who have
guns and love their guns I don't have a
gun I never had a gun
um
I mean I had Pelican I think a BB gun
but I that song is just about my
reaction to how insane the news is this
bizarre idea that keeps coming up is
like let's not make it political just
because another 10 people got mowed down
let's not make it's like I don't give a
about the politics I don't give a
I'm just saying
I don't want people to get shot
for going to school or for going to the
office or for going to University or for
going the you know going to the mall and
so the song is simply that it's like I
you know I'm just afraid I'm afraid I'm
not trying to choose sides here but it
seems like if we make those issues
issues like guns political issues that's
a really good way to not deal with real
issues
[Music]
think something to tell my baby is
self-explanatory I'm really grateful
came quick it was a fast song boom
this is what it is and if you listen to
that song I think what it is is clear
about
death and about family what would I hope
um my musical Legacy is you know things
come and go quickly nowadays you know so
I hope it casts a pretty Shadow but I
don't know how long it'll last you know
I hope that the people that I love
remember that I wasn't so much of a dick
for the most part